If you've been following visual politics
for a long time,
you already know that Argentina is in
dire straits and they need to ask for
loans from international investors.
In these cases,
the usual procedure is to print what we
call a debt bonds.
This is a piece of paper that says,
if you give me this amount of money,
I'll give it back to you in say 10 years
with some interest far so good,
but that's mentioned this situation.
Let's say that you lend three thousands,
Argentinian pesos to the Argentinian
governments at the time.
We're making this video,
the summer of 2018,
those 3000 pesos equal a hundred
American dollars,
but what would happen in the year 20,
28?
Well,
the thing is we just don't know,
but the chances are the Argentinian
currency will have been devalued more
and more by then.
Maybe 3000 pesos wouldn't even buy you a
bag of Doritos.
Yes.
This is why international investors
smart as they are,
say to Argentina,
wait a minute,
dude.
I mean,
I will lend you the money,
but you got to denominate that debt in
dollars,
man.
American dollar is not your funky
dollars this way.
I give you $300 and you give me back
$300 plus interest.
Got It.
My dear viewer,
this is how an investor protects himself
from would be devaluations,
but hold on a second here because we're
not just talking about Argentina.
In fact,
most the world's countries choose the
greenback as the currency in which they
issue that notes,
and this is why you can read headlines
like this in every financial newspaper,
Mexican government will issue bonds
denominated in US dollars to be repaid
in 10 years.
As you can imagine,
we're not just talking about government
set.
For example,
anytime Aramco,
the Saudi Arabian Oil Company wants to
sell their dinosaur juice to say India.
They'll say something like,
Whoa,
hold on.
What are these?
I don't even know how much these coins
are worth.
Do you got to pay in dollars?
My Man American dollars?
Because that is the currency I can
trust.
This explains why 60 percent of all
foreign currency reserves around the
world are held in dollars for one point
six,
$7,000,000,000,000 in circulation around
the world.
More than half of them are outside the
United States.
There is no international law that says
that the dollar must be used as the
global reference,
but most people trust the dollar as the
currency for international trade.
And here comes the big question.
What is this use for?
I mean,
how does America benefit from having
their currency circulating all over the
place?
Well,
it kind of depends.
If you're a company or a regular
citizen,
this is completely irrelevant for you.
We could say it's actually worse,
but if you are the American government's
well having a good time.
So why having a good time?
I'll let me explain full of dollars.
We told you a thousand times aerovision
politic.
The worst thing that can happen to a
currency as hyperinflation.
This means that all of a sudden prices
go absolutely sky high,
but how is hyperinflation created in the
first place?
Right?
No,
the answer to this,
in most cases,
this is a 100 percent monetary
phenomenon.
If central banks printing money,
like there's no tomorrow,
the currency devalues,
but why is this?
What's the connection between printing
money and losing the value of that
money?
You see,
when we talk about currency,
we have to consider it just like any
other products.
Yep.
Yeah.
That right.
Currencies work under the same
principles as oil or oranges or mobile
phones,
and that of course there's supply and
demand.
So for example,
a Venezuelan bolivar has very little
demand they need Venezuelans uses.
So when the Central Bank of Venezuela
print see ton of boulevard,
this expands the supply of the currency
and the price falls.
This means that the currency devalues
nonetheless,
the demands for the American dollar.
It doesn't stop growing.
Everybody around the globe uses it for
international trade.
This means that the Federal Reserve has
a huge margin to print money before
risking any sort of evaluation.
And you might be wondering,
well,
why would the Federal Reserve wants to
print more
money?
All right,
so let's have a look at an example.
Imagine you've lent $100 to the American
government and now you want them to pay
you back.
So you go to the American government and
they're essentially tell you,
sure man,
I ain't got your money.
How much is it?
$100.
No problem.
Do you just go to that building?
The one next door is a big federal
reserve on the outside.
Go in there and tell them to print you
100 bucks and now whip it out in just a
second.
No worries.
This process is called monetizing debt
and when you tell things like this to
your smart ass friend,
the one who thinks he's an expert in Geo
politics,
he will have no idea what you're talking
about,
but the truth is that this hegemonic
currency is what allows America to issue
more and more debt and do it more easily
than any other country.
And this is why it is so normal to find
headlines.
Gas,
the crisis is coming.
Interest payments will hit a trillion
dollars a year.
Having such a big debt is not really
great news for American taxpayers.
In this previous video we told you
exactly why,
but hold on a second because I can
probably guess what you're thinking
right now.
You're probably thinking,
well,
isn't America as irresponsible with its
monetary policy is Argentina or
Venezuela?
And the answer to that is,
well,
the absolutely not.
You see all the central banks print new
bills year after year.
Not only do they print it,
but they generate more money
electronically as well.
The difference is just on the
proportions on this chart,
you can see the increase of the monetary
supply,
what we call the end to indicator of the
American Federal Reserve.
As you can see,
the number of dollars grows year after
year.
But what happens if we compare it with
say the Argentinian peso?
Well,
she could see the difference and what
happens when we compare it with the
Venezuelan boulevard.
Well,
I need to comment here,
and just nine years,
Venezuela is multiplied them monetary
supply by 100,
but America,
they've not even doubled.
Now for a bonus facts while making this
chart,
we decided not to include the year 2018
because otherwise the yellow part would
just cover everything.
This year the Central Bank of Venezuela
is multiplied than monetary supply by
for thousands,
and this is why the American dollar is
the most used currency on the planet and
that's because it's stable.
While other central banks print money
like crazy,
the Federal Reserve is actually pretty
responsible and they might be wondering,
well,
what about other agencies like the Swiss
franc or the British pounds?
I mean,
if there's one stable currency in the
world,
right?
It's got to be the Swiss franc.
Yeah.
Well your rights in fact,
pay attention to this part of the video
because this is going to surprise you
despite the importance.
It is not the only reserve currency on
the planet far from us.
In fact.
So check this out.
Multicurrency world.
We said it at the beginning of this
video.
Sixty percent of the foreign currency
reserves a hells in greenbacks,
but well,
what about the other 40 percent?
The second most used currency in the
world as a reserve currency is the euro
which represents about 20 percent of
global foreign currency reserves for
that follows the Japanese yen and the
sterling pound.
But these are not the only currencies
used as reserve currencies.
Many central banks also hold Australian
dollars brief and Swiss francs as
reserves.
But the question here is,
if what you need for a currency to have
a high demand is to be stable,
why don't we use Swiss francs as much as
we use?
And the
answer simply is because there are way
less Swiss francs.
Think about it.
Switzerland has eight point 5 million
inhabitants.
The United States,
they got 300 million.
This means that the Swiss National Bank
doesn't need to issue as many bills.
The how I said that the world has one
point six,
$7,000,000,000,000 in it,
while the Swiss franc doesn't even have
a single tridion.
This means that it's harder to find
frank's than it is to find dollars to do
a transaction on the other hands.
America is the world's biggest market.
This means that thousands of companies
from all over the world sell their
product set.
So imagine you're an Australian company
and you're selling mobile phones in New
York.
How do they pay you?
Well,
of course they'd be paying you with
American dollars.
So what do you then do with those green
bags?
Well,
you've changed them to your local
currency.
So now he will have the American cash.
Well,
of course that would be the Australian
Bank where you made the exchange.
In other words,
the more America trades with the worlds
of the more dollars will circulate
around the globe.
This is a currency that is stable,
abundant,
and supported by the biggest economy
decades ago.
No other currency can be a match for the
green back.
But as you know,
the wells is certainly changing.
And at this point you can probably see
where I'm going with this video.
At the beginning of this video I asked
you,
is it possible that the dollar will lose
their hedge money or at least be less
important than it is today?
And the answer to that,
absolutely
us trumpets,
America first.
The rest of the world is moving on.
We've been telling you week after week
here on visual politic that Donald trump
wants to protect America from
international trade.
His first move was to cancel the free
trade agreements with the EU and Asia.
After this,
he introduced terrorists to steal,
so companies like Harley Davidson,
uh,
leaving the country,
trump has also announced that he wants
to end Nafta,
which is the trade agreements between
the US,
Canada,
and Mexico.
In other words,
trump's America wants to isolate itself
from the international markets.
So what does all this mean?
Well,
it means that these other countries will
have less dollars and you've got to add
other news like this ends of the met.
Central banks are starting to replace
dollar reserves with the you are,
or maybe there's other
plans,
one bond sale with sanctions threat near
him.
It is true that the Chinese yuan used to
be almost an unknown currency in the
international markets.
It was only used inside of China.
Nonetheless,
in recent years,
some central banks are starting to buy
it,
but of course this doesn't mean that
banks will start changing all of their
dollars to this currency overnight.
In fact,
there are any things we don't know about
the Chinese currency,
things that your friends that smart ass
probably won't know about either,
but don't worry because in the following
weeks we're going to be doing a
continuation on this video,
so please don't forget to subscribe to
visual politic and click on the bell
icon so you don't miss any posts.
Sneak wall here.
We have some questions for you.
Do you think the dollar can maintain its
hedge money and the following decades,
and if north,
what are the currency do you think?
Should substitute as maybe the yuan,
maybe the euro,
perhaps bitcoin.
Well,
neither in the comment section below,
and please don't forget to visit our
friends from the reconsider media
podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that went on mine,
and if you liked this video,
please give us a thumbs up and as always
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
more of my lovely voice,
don't forget to check out reconsidered
podcast@reconsidermedia.com.
We consider as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your abuse by
providing context,
but we don't do the thinking.